there is a new app for consensual sex so
you know there's a gajillion apps we all
know about Grindr and tinder GPS base
app you find somebody that wants the
same stuff that you want you're within
12 feet of them and you get to do your
thing but now there is an app let's take
a look at it right now it is called good
to go and we're good to go is it's not
GPS based this is just if you are if you
know somebody so let's pretend you're
you're a college you're at a party you
decide you're gonna hook up with
somebody you guys both go into your app
and you basically agree to say that
you're gonna have consensual sex and
it's a-you know there's you can see
right there on the right side whether
you're sober mildly intoxicated
intoxicated but good to go pretty wasted
and basically this is a consent thing
this is not who you're gonna you know
this is not meeting somebody this is
just about consent so it seems good
intention like we do a lot there's all
these terrible stories about rape and
all this horrible stuff
is this really gonna prevent rape that's
right because what rapist is going to
download and you bring up a good point
this is going to prevent a rapist and I
think when you look at the data that the
app is collecting probably not because
it's really it's really interesting when
you look at the fact that the data being
collected is all of the affirmative data
so whenever you have cases of yes I
consent yes I consent the app keeps it
but when you have cases of no consent
the app does not store that data which I
found earlier which I don't really think
your point of this app so that somebody
could show it in a courtroom exactly oh
sure but it would only essentially favor
that via cues not be big done yes okay
so I have a problem with that and when
you say this is the consent app I think
this is more of a data app because
really what they're doing is asking you
for your information you know how your
what your sexual behaviors like
intoxication your age email addresses so
that's where I think you know this
company is looking to make money I
really don't think they care about
consent yes so okay so let's go to the
data part of it because yeah every every
week we do something else on the NSA or
data
Google's collecting your data someone
look at here what is the last bastion
stay out of my bedroom also I'm sorry
it's not hot like I'm not gonna like I
just I don't be handed me their phone
and they're like gee I'm like I'm not in
the mood now I have to say no because he
pulled out the [ __ ] app thank you
happy creators of this app ever had sex
I don't think I've ever been like oh
would you like to have sex yes would oh
yeah sure I would like to have sex like
that didn't happen either yeah it's just
crazy and right so the data part of this
though so yes it's not sexy like for
sure it's just you know yes I don't like
at the end of a - like now we're just
giving everybody more now we're
literally bringing them into the bedroom
and then there's a potential for abuse
here - right so that that's the other
part that really concerns me for you
know besides the taking out the sexy
part of it whatever right there's a
potential for abuse because if say I
were really intoxicated I don't think
that I'd be able to like hold my phone
and like click on the functions that I'm
supposed to click on and the fourth
prompt saying yes or whatever and the
person next to me if not intoxicated can
so they can easily take my phone keys
punch a button away yeah what's to say
that they can't fill it out for you and
your way can you go away wait what's
your email address like if you just like
dribble it out and they put it in and
that's the proof you get roofied
I mean it's insane do you guys think
that the technology is ruining sex
basically really like that you can get
the type of sex you want automatically
you that easily that they have you know
this type of app that all this stuff
that it really is changing sex like
really really but I think it takes all
types I would not want to live in a
world that didn't have vibrators right
you know that's technology that I think
revolutionized sex so it definitely it
takes outside using it mode above the
team I don't my phone is not on vibrate
it would just be too exciting no but I
definitely think it takes all types and
it depends on who you are and whether or
not it works for you I mean there's some
you know technology that's made sex
awesome there's
technology that yes is totally a huge
bummer the thing I like about this app
is that it's bringing awareness to
consent right now you know California
just passed its first consent law or yes
mean yeah yes means yes and the
universities we college students need to
get an affirmation so what I have so
many thoughts on that but I think that
the point here is that we do have a
culture where you know grape or
different variations of sexual assault
are more and more permitted and this is
elevating a conversation saying we need
to do something about it so perhaps is
them this is a misguided attempt but
it's well-intentioned
[Music]